[Music]
our story begins in an ancient forest in
the remote town of East vandermonde
Colin and Sylvia two college students on
spring break are hiking through the
forest why did you want to come all the
way here Sylvia we're in the middle of
nowhere we should be studying for our
probability course perhaps we are
what are you doing these humans won't
understand our sacred identities
patience my friend they will learn what
is this : and Silvia don't know what to
make of the scroll they have found
that's impossible
it looks like they just added to a and B
to get a plus B and added the K and C
minus K to get see what kind of
birdbrain would come up with a formula
like this it looks mysterious and
beautiful but that hardly means it isn't
true let's try some examples and see if
we can prove or disprove it
Collin remembers from stat 110 how a
binomial coefficient and choose K can be
defined in terms of factorials n
factorial over N minus K factorial K
factorial he tries a couple examples on
his calculator it is true in those
examples so he proceeds to work on a
proof using algebra it's more of a
mystery than ever I wonderful ever know
if this formula is always true or how
anyone could have come up with it
actually I can prove it in a few
sentences with no algebra needed ah look
at the birds they will show you
Sylvia reminds Colin that they learned
in stat 110 that the binomial
coefficient and choose K can also be
defined by a story it's the number of
ways to choose a committee of size K
from n people or the order in which
people are chosen doesn't matter it's
the number of subsets of size K for a
set of size n it's the number of flocks
of K birds that can be formed by
choosing birds from a flock of n birds
IC peacocks and toucans flying around
trying to get on the top branches but
what does that have to do with the
formula on the scroll let's say there
are a peacocks and b2 cans vying for the
six top branches the number of
possibilities for which birds get to
perch on top branches is a + b choose 6
that's the right hand side when C is 6
okay but what about the left hand side
the left hand side just breaks this into
cases if there is one peacock perched on
a top branch there must be 5 toucans
perched on top branches if there are 2
peacocks
there must be 4 - cans if there are K
peacocks
there must be C minus K two cans so
count how many possibilities there are
for which K peacocks and which c minus K
two cans are on top branches then sum up
the cases since we want the total number
of possibilities
not just the number for one value of K
the formula on the scroll is called
Vander Mons identity Sylvia has just
discovered a story proof of this
identity she has given it an
interpretation rather than doing tedious
or intractable algebra both sides of the
identity count the same thing so they
must be equal Sylvia gave her proof for
the case C equal to 6 because she was
looking at a tree with six top branches
but the same idea works for any value of
C and Ehrman's identity is a handy
result that often comes up in problems
involving binomial coefficients thinking
about it in terms of a story makes it
easier to remember and understand the
moral of the story is to look for a
story
[Music]
you
you